micheline n'en revient pas elle vient
d'apprendre qu'elle devra payer pour
l'entretien du lot où son grand-père
hector est enterré en 1944 accor avait
pourtant bien fait les choses
il avait acheté son lot par contre il
avait aussi signé un contrat d'entretien
à perpétuité et on a même pris la peine
de préciser perpétuité égale toujours
hector s'est-il fait avoir il ya 70 ans
non ce genre d'erreur était courant dans
le québec de ces années là
à l'époque les directions de cimetières
croyais qu'on pouvait vendre l'eau et
son entretien perpétuel et c'était sans
compter avec le code civil du québec
plus fort que tous ses contrats de vente
le kof dit qu'il était possible
d'acheter un look dans un cimetière ce
qu'on obtient en échange de la somme
pays
c'est plutôt un droit de concession
sorte le bail d'une durée maximum de 100
ans lille contrat d'entretien qui s'y
rattachent est à l'avenant il ne peut
durer lui aussi plus de 100 ans
souhaitons seulement qu'hector ne te
retourne pas dans sa tombe